Kennen Sie das auch?
Ja. Fuck! Kennen Sie das auch? Sie wollen eine energetische Podcast-Folge aufnehmen, aber die Mikrofonständer streiken? Fuck! Nein! Es ist immer so gut, wenn in diesen Schwarz-Weiss-Videos immer noch so eine Tonspur dabei wäre, wo die Leute irgendwie so ihre Schüssel Popcorn umwerfen und so Fuck you! I hate this! Ist das nicht etwas Einfacheres? Ich sag einen Satz und du führst ihn zu Ende. Herzlich willkommen zu Das Podcast UFO heute mit Stargästen, wirklich, wer hätte das gedacht, Florian Tietz ist heute bei uns und Stefan Tietze. Vielen Dank für die Einladung, auch vielen Dank an Stefan Tietze, dass er es heute einrichten konnte. Ja, ganz gerne. Wieder bei uns da sein. Ich muss noch ganz kurz meinen Popschutz rücken. Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO, Podcast UFO. Ey, wusstest du übrigens, nehme ich schon auf, wusstest du, dass ich finde Stadiongesänge echt so ein interessanter Aspekt. Geht so. Ich finde, die haben diese, sobald man im Stadion singt, ich weiß nicht, ob du das schon mal gemacht hast, aber natürlich in Dortmund großgewachsen, da fährt man schon mal die BVB an und man hat direkt so eine ganz andere Stimme.
Auch als Zwölfjähriger hat man teilweise schon diese und nach dem Spiel redet man auch so dann privat.
Aber spannenderweise sind die Melodien, die die da singen, oft einfach sehr sehr klassisch und hochinteressante
klassische Lieder. Beispiel
Verdi. Das singen die im Stadion, ist mir noch einmal aufgefallen.
Forza BVB, BVB, BVB, BVB, Hallee, Forza BVB, B. Aber die singen das natürlich ja nicht so, sondern Hallee, Forza B, V, B, Forza B. Aber das ist echt interessant. Ich finde das, ich meine, natürlich ist Fussball männlicher Sport. Man singt männlich, man steht auf der Bühne, reißt sich das Trikot vom Leib und steht dann da männlich, yeah, mit der Bierbrinkinkopf Nummer eins, yeah. Und dann singen die aber eigentlich eine Oper. Ich finde das einen spannenden Konflikt, wo sich da befinden eigentlich. Ja, das stimmt, das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an Rap eigentlich, wo es auch irgendein findiger Deutschlehrer in Amerika hat es geschafft, zu sagen, hey, mach doch mal irgendwie Gedichte, aber dazu irgendwie klopf, Jannis, Jannis, klopf du mal bitte so in einem Rhythmus auf den Tisch und wir lesen Gedichte dazu und plötzlich so, yo, that was dope, motherfucker, und dann gehen die raus und machen die Battles und sich in Gedichte schreiben. Wie kann ich den Kindern Gedichte nahe bringen? Hm, vielleicht lassen sie sich gegenseitig beleidigen ein bisschen, das war ja vielleicht der Erste, der so Battle, Rap Battles aufgebaut hat, im Klassenraum. So, die Sophia, die macht dann mal gegen den Mark und wir sehen mal, wo das hinführt. Und dann reimt man einfach ein bisschen. Ihr könnt auch ruhig Schimpfwörter benutzen. Und die Kinder so und der Lehrer hat sich ins Fäustchen gelacht, weil er es endlich rausgefunden hat. Ich glaube, der Lehrer ist irgendwie so ein ganz gemütlicher Lehrer, der noch heute irgendwo in Staten, Ohio oder so. Irgendwie so ein dücklicher Typ, der vielleicht so einen Labrador-Hunt hat, der dann auf Facebook postet, oh, der ist leider krank, könnt ihr mir nicht was spenden und dann machen die so einen Kuchenverkauf und dann sammeln die Geld zusammen für den Labrador-Hund und dann geht's ihm wieder gut und Poffi geht's wieder gut, aber der hat Rap erfunden, der hat irgendwie damals im Deutelkart gesagt, so, ach, jetzt machen wir mal irgendwie Goethe ein bisschen verrückt heute mal. Was hat er noch erfunden? Was hat er noch erfunden? Weil, also, Metal ist ja auch quasi Klassik mit Elektro-Metal. Ja, Metal ist halt verrückter Rock'n'Roll. Also, wem Rock'n'Roll noch nicht verrückt genug ist, der legt nochmal ordentlich einen Gang zu. Oh, da kann ich dir nicht folgen auf diesem Weg. Mir ist Rock'n'Roll schon ein bisschen zu verrückt. Geht's eigentlich, was ist die härteste Musik? Also, weil das ist ja auch so ein, also damals, als Mozart ja aktiv war, war das ja auch so total crazy. Das war ein Punker. So, boah, wie kann man das machen? Siehst du, er folgt auf Ass und what the fuck. Okay, ich wollte jetzt den Gag machen, der hat den Song Leck mich im Arsch. Der hat einfach harte Songs an den Tag gebracht. Ja. Aber du hast recht, das war einfach ein Punk damals. Und ich weiß nicht genau, was da das äquivalent heute zu ist, zu Mozart. Wahrscheinlich ein Punk. Wir sind halt heute so eine liberale Gesellschaft, dass es halt diese Rebellionen nicht mehr so hundertprozentig gibt. Ach so Scheiße. Die echten Punks werden dann halt irgendwie so Rechte oder sowas, die halt dann wirklich verbotene Sachen machen. Oder Jura-Leute, Rechtswissenschaftler. Aber heute ist ja so Heavy Metal, so Deathcore, die müssen sich auch in den Begriffen immer wieder überbieten.
Also es gibt dann Black Metal, Death, Horror, Terror Metal, das wird dann auch irgendwann,
hört dann die Sprache auf zu funktionieren, wo man dann einfach nur noch irgendwie mit Begriffen arbeiten muss.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade bei Musik sind, ich habe jetzt von Spotify die beste Mail des Jahres bekommen,
mega spannend, dein 2016 in Musik.
Ja, die Mail habe ich nicht bekommen. Das ist seltsam,
wahrscheinlich weil du wieder so ein
E-Mail-Messi bist, aber das
ist interessant, ich habe 12.752
Minuten
insgesamt Musik gehört.
So, das sind 12.000,
das sind ungefähr 600 Stunden,
habe ich mal ausgerechnet.
Im Jahr, 600 Stunden. Das ist nicht
so viel. 633 Künstler. Und dann... Wie heißt denn der Absender der Mail? Dann kann ich den mal suchen. Spotify. Ja, aber die Mailadresse... Hello at Spotify.com. Oh, jetzt haben wir die im Internet verraten. Ja, ist kein Ding. Prankt den mal so richtig, Leute. Meldet den mal irgendwie bei MyHustle oder bei irgendwie Grindr an, Leute, dann pranken wir heller als Spotify.com. Ich habe keine Meldung. Und ich gehöre zu den Top 1% der Fans von Stephen King und von John Williams. Aber was heißt das? Also, der Leute, die John Williams hören, ich bin Top 1 Prozent der Fans von John Williams. Das heißt, ich höre überdurchschnittlich viel John Williams in einer Gruppe, die schon überdurchschnittlich viel John Williams hört. Aha. Ich weiss auch nicht genau. Was macht das aus mir? Die Frage wäre doch jetzt, was ist die Musikrichtung, die du am wenigsten hörst. Also wie wäre es denn, wenn Spotify für eine
Woche mal deinen Musikgeschmack
...
Weiß nicht, was ist passiert?
Ich habe auf die Mail geklickt.
Das ist alles
Copyright rechtlich ein bisschen kritisch
gerade, aber wäre doch cool, wenn
Spotify für eine Woche
deinen Musikgeschmack komplett invertiert,
komplett dreht einfach. Wenn davor alles so Hard Rock, Death Metal, dann alles so komplett irgendwie Hafen, ganz zarte Sachen und Folk und Schlager und so. Meinst du, man kann wie so ein Farbkreis so Musikrichtungen anlegen und dann einfach mal einmal einfach so, wie man das bei so einem Fotofilter auch machen kann, einfach so die Farben tauschen. Und es gibt ja diese eigene Statistik über Musikrichtungen und wie statistisch gesehen Leute einen höheren IQ haben, die die und die Musik hören. Und da war Beyoncé für die ganz dummen und Beethoven war für die ganz schlauen. So, dann habe ich gedacht, okay, vielleicht kann ich den Ursache-Wirkungs-Zusammenhang umkehren, indem ich jetzt sehr viel Beethoven höre einfach und dadurch schlauer werde. Das stimmt. War ziemlich blöd wahrscheinlich. Aber auf der anderen Seite... Aber hat wahrscheinlich auch was mit sozialen Schichten zu tun. Glaube ich auch und ich glaube auch hat damit zu tun, wie viel Musik du hörst, weil je mehr Musik du hörst, desto komplexere Musik hörst du auch gerne. Ah, das weiss ich. Auf jeden Fall. Moment mal. Das ist auch Wissenschein, die belegt. Aber was genau heißt das? Also heißt das dann, aber wenn du jetzt irgendwie als 14-Jähriger anfängst Hip-Hop zu hören und du hörst Hip-Hop dein ganzes Leben, dann heißt es, du hörst irgendwann immer komplexeren Hip-Hop oder würdest du sagen, du landest automatisch irgendwann bei Klassik, weil das die komplexere Musik kommt? Ja, du würdest dich zumindest nicht mehr verschliessen. Also die Sache ist ja die, Musik ist Mathematik. Eine normale Konsonante, Noten A und D ist dann die Subdominante und so Bullshit. So, das sind alles sehr einfache Zusammenhänge. Dominante Subdominante, das ist alles ganz easy so und dann fangen die Siebener-Akkorde an
und dann geht man Richtung Jazz, da wird es immer
komplexer und fürs nicht geschulte
Auge klingt das einfach nur wie ein
Wirrwarr, klingt das einfach wie ein
Pollock-Gemälde, aber wenn es
dann, irgendwann kannst du anfangen
das so rauszuhören, weil du auch
es ist wie Mathematik, wie gesagt, also du kennst
auch komplexere Formeln, checkst du eher, wenn du
dich da forschst, mal mit Formeln, die daraus bestehen.
Ja, aber es ist doch jetzt auch nicht so, dass wenn du dein ganzes Leben lang Filme anschaust, du kannst auch im hohen Alter auch noch irgendwie Crab wie Transformers anschauen.
Ja, du kannst genau, ja klar, genau, und so genau so hört dann der, der mit Hip-Hop sozialisiert wurde, auch gerne noch Hip-Hop-Song von Eminem, Easy, Slim Shady, Yeah, Nigga, jo, cool, aber ich es nicht, ich weiss auch immer, ich denk mir zum Beispiel auch immer, nur weil du etwas häufig tust, wird man darin automatisch besser oder nicht? Doch, klar. Das weiss ich nicht, zum Beispiel ich spiele Dota und ich werde nicht besser, ich werde einfach nicht besser, immer hänge ich an der gleichen Wertung rum, ich mache immer dieselben Fehler, ich bin immer schlecht. Aber weil du es als Freizeit auch nicht, vielleicht machst du es nicht, versuchst du nicht besser zu werden, vielleicht bist du zufrieden darüber. Aber ich glaube auch, dass besser werden, also nennen wir es mal lernen, auch eine Fähigkeit ist, die man haben oder nicht haben kann. Also jemand, der die Fähigkeit hat zu lernen, kann in zehn Stunden Dota spielen viel mehr erreichen, als jemand, der die Fähigkeit nicht hat, in hundert Stunden. Ist die Fähigkeit zu lernen, nicht Intelligenz? Puh, könnte man das natürlich eine Verbindung machen. Wow, du hast so heftig genickt, dass ich mir kurz Gedanken um deine Nackenmuskulatur gemacht habe. Aber das war jetzt gerade hochbrisant, was du gesagt hast. Das war eine hochbrisante Zustimmung auch. Ja, ja, das musst du in dem Jahr anpassen. Also meine Lieblingsmusikgenres sind Rock auf eins, Artrock auf zwei, Bluesrock auf drei, keine Ahnung, Mellow Gold, keine Ahnung und Softrock. Hätte ich nicht gedacht. Aber wie ist jemand, der sowas hört, dann Top eins der Fans von John Williams? Warte mal, ich versuche das mal gerade bei mir auch rauszufinden. Ja, das interessiert mich jetzt auch gerade echt, wo ich 1% bin. Bisschen schade, wenn da noch die Podcastaufnahme leitet, weil du jetzt die nächste Stunde am Tuchen bist.
Warte mal, unter Herunterladen oder wo? Es klingt einfach so scheiße, als würde, jetzt habe ich Spotify nochmal runtergeladen,
es klingt einfach so, als würde wir Werbung für Spotify machen, was wir auch guten Gewissens tun können, weil Spotify eine super Sache ist.
Okay, wir hören mal ganz kurz den Leuten in der Küche zu. Es gibt zwei Zipper. Oh, ist wohl eine Kontaktlinse rausgefallen. Der alte Karlau. Aber schreibt mal, wovon ihr Top 1 seid, Prozent Fans seid und schreibt mal, was ihr so von Musikrichtungen hört.
Wie heißt denn die Mail?
Dein 2016 in Musik, personalisierte Statistiken und Playlists. Aber du kriegst auch tausend Mails jeden Tag, weil du die Einstellungen auch irgendwie verballerst überall.
Und wann hast du die bekommen? Jetzt bekommen sie das spannendste, was du vorstiegst. Gestern um neun Uhr achtundvierzig. Gestern? Ja. Ja, ein bisschen so etwas würde ich mit meiner Oma, die schon tot ist, über Technik sprechen. Ja, ich glaube, ich habe die einfach nicht bekommen. Ja, zu diesem Fazit wäre ich jetzt auch gekommen. Schade, schade, schade. Schade, schade, ja. Aber versuch mal, die nochmal zu finden und vielleicht können wir da nächste Woche drüber sprechen. Auf jeden Fall sehr interessant. Was habt ihr herausgefunden? Wird mich mal interessieren. Wie war denn dein 2016? Nicht in Zahlen. Wie viele Kilo hast du abgenommen, wie viele Kilo hast du zugenommen? Oh, ich glaube, ich bin mittlerweile bei plus sechs Kilo. Krass. Momentan. Bei mir ist es so, ich habe jetzt eine Waage seit ungefähr einem halben Jahr. Habe ich vorher nie gehabt, habe ich nicht den Grundring gesehen, aber ich wollte einfach mal gucken, weil ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe echt so Sinuskurven mässig, werde ich fetter und wieder dünner und das ist wirklich so, also 90 Kilo ist mein Default und manchmal ich schwanke zwischen 92 und 88 tatsächlich immer Sinuskurven mässig und wenn ich das Gefühl habe, ich werde zu dick, esse ich halt einfach ein bisschen besser und dann geht es wieder ganz schnell runter. Und das ist wirklich so, man kann wirklich gucken einfach im Jahr und man sieht genau, das ist wie so eine Sinuskurve. Aber machst du das auch so, wenn du dich wiegst? Also ich habe so eine Digitalwaage, die in der Regel zweistellige Kiloanzahl und dann noch eine Nachkommastelle anzeigt. Und bei mir ist es oft so, pro Wiegesitzung wiege ich mich ungefähr so fünf bis sechs mal und nehme das Beste. Das arithmetische Mittel. Ja, oder das Beste. Einfach so, weil irgendwann, du kennst ja deine Waage irgendwann und du weißt so, okay, das erste Komma sieben, dann denkst du dir, da ist noch mehr drin, gehst nochmal drauf, Komma fünf, da geht noch ein bisschen was und dann Komma drei, okay, okay, okay, okay, besser wird's nicht. Meine Waage ist anders. Meine Waage, da gehst du drauf, dann braucht die ungefähr fünf Minuten, bis sie sich geeinigt hat. Das ist so eine sprunghafte Waage. Zeh, neunzig, komma sieben, nein, sechs, nein, drei, nein, fünf, nein, ganz anders, ein neunzig, nein, neunzig, drei, ähm, und dann ist es ein bisschen wie bei eins, zwei oder drei, wie die immer hin und her springen vorher. Und die letzte Chance, und dann bleibt sie irgendwo stehen, random. Das war nicht mal die Mitte aus allen Zahlen, die die zwischendurch gezeigt hat, das ist irgendeine Zahl. Und dann runde ich das meistens irgendwie auf oder ab. Nee, bei mir ist es wirklich so, bei mir ändert es sich nicht mehr, sobald man draufgestiegen ist, man muss dann wieder neue draufsteigen. Aber das so ein bisschen, damit es eigentlich Einstein widerlegt, der gesagt hat, irgendwie so Wahnsinn ist. Ich glaube nicht, dass wir in unserem 12-Euro-Wagen einsteigen. Doch, doch, der hat ja sowas gesagt wie, Wahnsinn ist, wenn man immer dasselbe macht, aber andere Ergebnisse erwartet. Aber genau das passiert. Ich drehe drauf, Komma sieben, runter, drauf, Komma fünf, runter, drauf, Komma neun, es ist immer was anderes. Es ist immer so, als würde man einen anderen Mitarbeiter zugeordnet bekommen und der das immer so leicht anders macht. Nö, nö, das müssen Sie nicht stempeln, das passt schon. Und selber die ein bisschen übergewichtige Frau, die runden uns ein bisschen ab. Ja, genau. Oh, komm, ja, ja, der ist nicht so, der ist nicht dick. Aber ich versuche dann auch immer, wenn es dann an Komma null geht, möglichst noch auf Komma neun der unteren zu kommen. Ah, klar. Damit ich möglichst noch ein Kilo weniger riebe. Wo man auch in den Bauch einzieht und sowas, was gar keinen Sinn macht. Manchmal denke ich, ich lehme mich langsam an die Wand ab und denke, komm, ein bisschen Gewicht kannst du mehr abnehmen, komm schon. Das finde ich nicht schlecht, ja. Jedenfalls hatte ich gestern einen ganz, ganz seltsamen Tag und ich habe unangemessen belustigt reagiert, was nachher falsch war, aber ich versuche es mal einzuordnen. Jetzt habe ich mir gestern Essen bestellt bei Foodora. Und die letzten paar Male ist da immer was schiefgelaufen. Die haben immer mir eine SMS geschickt, ja, hier Essen kommt später und so. Und die haben irgendwie nichts ganz hingekriegt. Ich wohne auch auf der anderen Reihenseite. Und die meisten Restaurants sind auf der anderen Reihenseite. Und die fahren dann mit dem Fahrrad immer. Gewährleisten haben immer 30 Minuten Lieferzeit. Das kann aber schon nicht funktionieren, weil es 30 Minuten weit weg ist, halt schon einfach. Und dann sagte ich denen immer, ja okay, ich gebe denen immer eine neue Chance. Ich dachte, ihr macht das das nächste Mal besser, ihr müsst mir auch die halbe Stunde nicht gewährleisten und so weiter. Und dann kam gestern, aber kam das Essen überhaupt nicht an. Und dann stand dann, dann kann man ja auch immer live tracken, die Fahrräder sind ja auch live getrackt. So dann habe ich ihn brein, so langsam von der Strömung so,auf an so, kann ich einen neuen Lieferanten haben, bitte? Und dann stand da, Maximilian ist auf dem Weg zu dir. Und dann kam der Punkt doch immer näher, immer näher, immer näher. Und dann war er irgendwann weg. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, das kann ja natürlich sein, ich hab den eh nicht geglaubt. Ich dachte immer, das ist so, die checken ungefähr, wo du bist, die checken ungefähr, wo das Restaurant ist und der geht einfach so auch durch den Reihen durch, manchmal das Fahrrad. Und dann stand plötzlich aber, Daniel ist auf dem Weg zu dir. Okay, dann dachte ich mir auch, die Namen sind doch auch random, die nehmen doch irgendwelche Namen. Und dann kam Daniel und fing Daniel plötzlich wieder vom Restaurant an. Und dann habe ich mich gewundert, was denn... Und dann hat es auch viel zu lange gedauert, dann habe ich mich beschwert im Chat und er hat gesagt, ja sorry, ich weiß auch nicht, was gerade los ist bei bei dir und er hat gesagt, ja, das letzte Mal einfach schon scheiße gewesen bei euch, was ist denn da los eigentlich, liegt es an meinem Wohnort oder so, ja, keine Ahnung, muss man im Einzelfall gucken, alles klar, ich warte und warte und kommt halt nichts und er stand immer noch, Daniel ist auf dem Weg zu dir jetzt und dann kam ein Anruf plötzlich und dann hat sie sich gemeldet und dann hat sich herausgestellt, dass Maximilian vor meiner Haustür einen Unfall hatte und das Essen
über die Straße geflogen ist.
Und dann
musste der ins Krankenhaus gebracht werden
und dann haben die neun Fahrer,
da kommt einfach einer nach,
und dann haben die den Fahrer noch mal zum Restaurant
geschickt und der hat mir das Essen dann noch mal
besorgt. Neben der Leiche
seines Kollegen stehen. Und dann kam der zu mir und der hat mir dann das Essen gebracht. Aber das ist für mich so beeindruckend und noch guter, wenn ich es, wenn dann irgendwie so, also Maximilian steht auf, ich habe mich auch erst gewundert, warum ein neuer Name da stand plötzlich, aber es war wirklich einfach ein neuer Fahrer, der dann kommen musste. Sehr schön. Und ich musste wirklich lachen, da habe ich auch gefragt, ich habe dann wirklich am Telefon einfach gelacht und dann war es so lustig einfach, dass er vor meiner Haustür einen Unfall hatte, so als wäre ich, als würde ich in Mordor leben und es wäre irgendwie gefährlich, zu mir zu kommen oder so. Und vor allem alle, oh nein, Tietze, bitte nicht Tietze, nein, nein, nein! Wir haben schon zwei Leute verloren, ich mach's. Aber gut wäre es auch gewesen, wenn du so hungrig gewesen wärst, deswegen, ja das ganze Essen ist über die Straße vorbei, deswegen sollen wir einen neuen losschicken? Nee, schon okay, ja, aber ich stehe trotzdem mal kurz auf. Mit dem Teller und der Gabel auf die Straße raus. Ich dachte kurz, bevor ich an die Gesundheit des Pfarrers gedacht habe, dachte ich kurz an, wow, zwei Essen, geil, mal kurz darauf auf die Straße zu gehen, mit so einem Steakmesser. Ja, es wäre auch gut, wenn du im Krankenhaus angerufen hättest, den Typen und jetzt so. Ja, aber hast du das Essen?
Also ist die Box aufgegangen oder ist nur die Box auf die Straße gefallen?
Dann habe ich gefragt, er darf gerade nicht sprechen, ja, ganz kurz noch.
Ja, ja, ja, aber können Sie ihm auf den Zettel schreiben, ob das Essen...
Einmal nicken, ne, einmal zwinkern ist ja, zweimal nein. Und dann habe ich aber gefragt, wie geht es ihm denn gut und so, ja, der kann ja heute nicht mehr fahren. Und oh, anscheinend hat der wirklich einen heftigen Unfall gehabt. Aber noch geiler fände ich es, wenn die so einen Service einblenden würden, weil es stand oben ja, Maximilian ist auf dem Weg zu dir. Und dann fände ich es geil, wenn irgendwann stehen würde, ja, Maximilian ist nicht mehr auf dem Weg zu dir, der ist jetzt auf dem Weg ins Krankenhaus. Maximilian ist auf dem Weg der Besserung oder sowas, wenn dann einfach Dinge, wenn der Live-Tracker noch ein bisschen geiler wäre. Ja, und den gesamten Alltag miterleben. Ja, das finde ich schön. Aber ich dachte, es hat wirklich viele Illusionen für mich zerstört. Auch die Namen sind offensichtlich die richtigen Namen. Das fand ich ganz beeindruckend. Aber abstrabo, Bestellung, hast du mitbekommen, Amazon mit den Supermärkten?
Nee.
Das hast du nicht gesehen, es ist total viral, das große Video jetzt, Amazon machte Supermärkte, und zwar gehst du da mit deinem Smartphone rein und dann gehst du durch so ein Tor rein und dann checkt dein Smartphone, okay, du bist jetzt in so einem Laden und dann nimmst du dir aus den Regalen einfach das, was du haben willst und dein Smartphone checkt durch Zukunftsmagie, checkt einfach, welche Gegenstände du an dir hast und du gehst mit denen einfach raus und es wird automatisch von deinem Google-Konto abgebucht, was du brauchst. Du gehst rein, nimmst die Sachen, gehst raus und dann checkt es, was du in der Hand hast. Dann wäre es interessant jetzt, herauszufinden, wie viel man kaputt machen kann, indem man Dinge falsch einsortiert. So, jetzt würde ich nämlich in Läden gehen, wo ein Kumpel von mir arbeitet, der immer die teuren Chips bei den billigen Spaghetti einsortiert, und würde mir dann da die Spaghetti rausnehmen und hätte viel weniger bezahlt eigentlich. Ja, ja. Es ist echt weird, weil da kann ja jetzt nicht irgendein Sensor an. Diese Arroganz zu behaupten, dass sie genau diesen Trick vergessen haben und übersehen haben. Weil ich meine, die können ja jetzt nicht irgendwie an jedem Sellerie da einen Sensor dran bringen. Das heißt, da wird irgendwie ein Strichcode dran sein vielleicht und dann das Handy checkt halt durch Magie, dass du das bei dir hast. Aber was passiert, wenn du einfach Waren in dem Laden auf den Boden wirfst, aber da lässt? Also wenn du einfach die ganze Milch... Im Laden konsumierst. Du nimmst einfach die Milch und wirfst sie auf den Boden und gehst. Was passiert dann? Weil es gibt ja genug antikapitalistische Leute, die ja keinen Bock drauf haben oder gegen Amazon sind oder generell gegen das System sind. Die werden... Ich meine, das kannst du im normalen Supermarkt auch machen eigentlich. Eigentlich kannst du ja gar nicht. Aber auch das Prinzip Dieb wird daraus einfach unmöglich. Ja, das stimmt. Aber du kannst einfach reingehen ohne Smartphone und Dingen mitnehmen. Das kannst du auch, oder? Ja gut, aber dann kommst du nicht durch die Schranke am Anfang. Du springst einfach drüber. Ich glaube, die Idee ist ja anscheinend auch, dass man Personalkosten reduziert. Aber ich glaube, da sind dann trotzdem noch ein paar Leute da, die einfach dann irgendwie aber schwer bewaffnet sind, die dann genau auf solche Sachen reagieren und die einfach jeden erschießen, der da ohne das Waffen reinkommt. Aber meiner Erfahrung nach sind Läden mit Security-Leuten immer die Läden, wo man am wenigsten klauen würde. H&M, Primark. Das ist eine ganz seltsame Sache. Warum sind da Security-Leute, aber nicht neben dem Rolex-Laden? Ich glaube, die Idee ist einfach von solchen Läden, dass einfach Abschreckung, dass er sowieso nichts machen könnte, wenn du klauen würdest, aber einfach Abschreckung. Die haben wahrscheinlich einfach rausgefunden, wenn so ein Security-Typ da ist, wird 40% weniger geklaut, das entspricht einem Marktwert von 4000 Euro im Monat, okay, davon können wir uns den Typen leisten, machen wir irgendwie noch 2000 Euro Gewinn, done. So, ganz einfach, durchgerechnet, fertig.
Wohingegen, wenn du wirklich Sicherheitsleute brauchst, die auch mal wirklich eine Uhr, die geklaut wird, fangen müssen,
dann hast du eher Leute im Zivil, die da nicht irgendwie in Uniform rumstehen,
sondern die halt den ganzen Tag so tun, als wären sie Kunden und sich einfach nicht entscheiden können
zwischen diesem Echtsilber und dem Platinring und den ganzen Tag so hin und her gehen.
Die auch im echten Leben dann Probleme haben, zu entscheiden, wenn die für die Familie einkaufen. Schatz, du bist ja wieder mit nichts nach Hause gekommen. Aber das ist leider einfach die Gewohnheit. Aber die sind so zivil, dass sie es auch nicht den Verkäufern sagen dürfen. Die Verkäuferin, kann ich ihnen helfen? Nee, aber sie müssen den ganzen Tag in dem Laden bleiben und können sich nicht entscheiden. Meine Theorie ist, dass die Security-Leute da sind, weil man am besten klauen kann da. Weil das sind halt so Kramläden. Primark, H&M, da kannst du einfach was nehmen und rausgehen. Wobei die sind ja gesichert perfekt schon. Ja, aber du würdest noch nicht bei dem Supermarkt bei dir um die Ecke klauen, weil da ist ja Hausverbot, ist ja das Schlimmste, was dir passieren kann, wenn du dann jeden Tag fünf Minuten weiter laufen musst. Das ist ja gar kein Sinn. Das ist ja gar kein Sinn. Du hast doch gesagt, bei so Laden, die Waren von geringem Preis haben, kann man eher klauen. Nein, H&M kann man ganz gut klauen, glaube ich, weil die immer so viele Sachen rumliegen, auch am Eingang rumliegen. Da kann man ja gut hin. Ach so. Also da kann man ja gut Dinge mitnehmen. Ich war mal im H&M und zwar in Berlin. Also ich habe nämlich erst die Operntickets gekauft und dann fiel mir ein, ah fuck, da kann man ja gar nicht im Pulli hingehen. Und dann bin ich in, und dann bin ich Goofy-mässig, bin ich dann in H&M gegangen, wo ich zum ersten Mal im H&M war und habe mir ein Hemd gekauft, weil es halt schön billig ist. Wo kaufst du denn sonst deine Sachen ein? Im Internet, zur Landenleitung. Und dann war ich da bei H&M und dann habe ich mir so Sachen genommen, Hemden genommen und dann muss man sich anstellen für die Umkleidekabinen. Ah ja, das hatte ich auch. Dann kriegst du für deinen Bügel so einen Aufsetzer, wo draufstehen, wie viele Waren du hast, damit die herausfinden, dass du mit genau der gleiche Anzahl an Waren zurückkommst, wie du reingegangen bist, damit du nichts klaust. Klar? Hey, warum in die Umkleide? In der Umkleide kannst du noch nichts klauen. Kannst du in die Tasche stecken oder in den Rucksack stecken. Ach so, okay. Und dann habe ich drei Hemden gehabt zur Auswahl, habe ich so ein großes Schild mit drei bekommen und bin reingegangen und dachte mir kurz, wie geil wäre es jetzt, mit vier Hemden rauszukommen. Ja, das stimmt. Das wäre das Beste. Kriegt man dann Applaus. Das wäre so eine geile Nummer für so einen Magier irgendwie. Ja, aber das ist doch auch eine gute Frage. Ist das denn überhaupt verboten, umgekehrten Diebstahl? Also, dass du jetzt zum Beispiel dein Stefan-Titze-Stand-Up-Special einfach bei Woolworth einfach als CD da reinstehst. So in... Oder halt irgendwo. Bei Cody. Ja, genau. Wo siehst du mein Stand-Up-Special an? Virgin Megastore. Das Erste, was dir eingefallen ist, ist Woolworth bei meinem Stand-Up-Special in 20 Jahren. Ja, wo man halt einfach so CDs kaufen kann. Ich sehe es bei Dehner, Gartencenter oder so, an der Kasse. Die machen auch nicht Haribo, die haben auch so eine Stranger-Auswahl an Süssigkeiten. Ja, das stimmt, ja genau. Die haben nicht mal Trolley, die haben wirklich die ganz komischen. Aber ist das denn verboten, wenn du dein, oder jetzt das Podcast-Ufo, Best-of-Podcast-Ufo-Album, und wir gehen zum Hugendubel und stellen die in die Regale rein, damit die Leute die kaufen. Machen aber auch Preisschilder hinten dran, oder was? Ja, oder schreiben halt kostenlos rein. Aber wir nutzen die Werbe- und Verkaufsfläche von den Läden um unser Zeug in den. Ist das verboten? Hat da nicht irgendwer von uns einen Bekannten, ich erinnere mich nicht mehr daran, aber dass die Filialbesitzer entscheiden, was im Laden steht.
Ja.
Das ist ganz strange.
Ja, das habe ich dir erzählt, ja.
Okay, ja, aber das ist, ich habe auch mal, wir haben damals so ein Hörspiel gemacht in der Schule,
und das wollten wir dann verkaufen in Läden.
Und dann kann man zum Filialleiter gehen, auch von so Mayer'sche Buchhandlungen und sowas,
das ist eine Kette, und die entscheiden nicht, wo was angeboten wird, sondern die Leute vor Ort,
die Filialleiter entscheiden, was angeboten wird, auch im Rewe und so. Ja.
Und diese
meierische Buchhandlung könnte sagen, fuck it,
wir verkaufen nur Detektiv Conan.
Nur. Bei uns gibt es nichts anderes.
Naja, es ist halt dann die Frage, also ich habe mich
mit so einer Filialeiterin von einem Supermarkt unterhalten
und die hat halt erzählt, dass sie ganz viele
Vertreter kennt und
bekommt, die halt zu ihr kommen, um die
neue Ware anzupreisen, weil die müssen
sie und sie allein überzeugen, damit sie das in ihren, gerade so saisonale Sachen oder jetzt, keine Ahnung, hat dann, was weiß ich, irgendwie Lindt, hat dann irgendwie so drei Special-Schokoladensorten und die, mit denen gehen dann halt die Vertreter von Laden zu Laden und versuchen die Filiale... Das ist der beste Job der Welt! Ja, ist es auch und die hatte auch total viele Sachen umsonst und so. Aber noch lieber als die Person
wäre ich der Lind-Vertreter.
Der Vertreter ist doch der beschissenste
Job der Welt, oder? Nein.
Warum, du musst denn ständig solche Sachen andrehen? Du weißt nicht, wovon du sprichst.
Du hast einen Koffer voller
Lind-Schokolade, oder? Ja, das stimmt natürlich.
Und damit könntest du dich einfach ins Ausland
absetzen. Ja, aber das ist tatsächlich,
also ich glaube, es gibt schon
sowas wie ein Grundset an Sachen, ich glaube, man kann
jetzt einfach so ein Nöfe verkaufen, keine Eier.
Ich dachte, du sagst, es gibt schon so ein Grundgesetz,
wo drinsteht, dass du nicht klauen darfst. Wo grundsteht,
dass die Menschen würde unantastbar ist. Ich glaube, das
gibt schon. Aber ich glaube,
so was, gerade sowas zu Special-Angebote und
wie das dann eingerechnet wird, dürfen die relativ viel
aber das ist ja total abgefahren, weil du
musst dir ja auch den
Platz kaufen, also den Platz in Regalen musst du dir ja auch kaufen. Ja, das ist klar. Also gerade zum Beispiel bei Eis, wo ja der Platz sehr limitiert ist, weil im Supermarkt kann ja nicht unendlich viel gekühlte Fläche haben. Wo kommt man da hin? Musst du ja, wenn du jetzt dein neues Eis hast, das Stefan-Titzer-Eis, musst du erstmal richtig viel Geld zahlen, weil die müssen ja anderes Eis aus ihrem Sortiment nehmen, um dein Scheisseis verkaufen zu können. Das heißt, du musst bestenfalls mehr Geld zahlen als andere. Das heißt, du musst schon erstmal richtig viel Geld in die Hand nehmen, um dir überhaupt diesen Verkaufsplatz zu kaufen, um überhaupt gekauft werden zu können, um dann wieder Geld zu bekommen. Ich habe ja mal versucht, aktiv den Netto hier zu beeinflussen. Netto, Oskar-Jäger-Strasse. Ja. einen Tag mal True-Fruits-Smoothies und die fand ich super, die haben sonst immer diese seltsamen Innocent-Smoothies, die furchtbar sind. So, und dann habe ich denen gesagt, einen Tag mal hatten die die True-Fruits, am nächsten Tag nicht mehr. Und dann bin ich zu der Filiale-Leiterin gegangen und habe gefragt, was ist eigentlich bei Ihnen hier los, hallo? Und habe da so einen Innocent-Smoothie auf ihre Schuhe gekippt und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, ich würde mir gerne wünschen, dass hier nochmal die Toolfoods stehen. Da meinte sie ja, die kamen nicht so gut an. Und hab gesagt, wer hat das gesagt, wer entscheidet das hier, wer von uns Kunden darf für uns alle sprechen. Und dann meinte sie ja, sie guckt nochmal. Dann hab ich überlegt, mich jeden Tag einfach, die vergisst, der locker weg bin, einfach jeden Tag zu ihr zu gehen und daran zu erinnern, wie gut Toofu sind. Man kann die beeinflussen aktiv.
Ja, bei mir war es tatsächlich auch so, dass in der Zeit, in der ich
abgenommen habe, kamen teilweise
sehr interessante, das fällt einem dann glaube ich mehr auf,
interessante Dinge im
kulinarischen Süßigkeitenspektrum aus. Zum Beispiel,
ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die kennt, diese
Milka-Tüten, also nicht
diese Tafeln, sondern diese Tüten,
wo dann teilweise, und es gibt dann die
Brezeln umhüllt von Schokolade, und dann gibt es auch Fruchtgummi umhüllt von Schokolade, und die sind richtig abgefahren, die sind richtig gut. Und ich wollte die kaufen, ich habe die gekauft, habe mich dann dazu entschieden abzunehmen, wollte die aber trotzdem unterstützen, ich wollte denen jetzt nicht das Signal geben, dass ich jetzt aufhöre, die zu kaufen, weil ich kann ja nicht an Milka schreiben so, nee, nee, nee, nee, Leute, die geil, aber ich kann jetzt euch leider kein Geld dafür geben. Und dann Schnitt, er geht nach Hause, macht so einen grossen Safe auf, wo er nur ganz schwer drankommt, wo so ein grosser Haufen von Produkten, die er unterstützen will. Ich hab mir allen Ernstes überlegt, die auch einfach zu kaufen und zu verschenken, weil ich einfach wollte, dass die Belohnung kriegen, weil ich hab mir immer den Typen vorgestellt, der gesagt hat, nee, Leute, ernsthaft, bitte, bitte, ihr müsst sowas machen wie Fruchtgummen mit Schokolade drum, das ist geil, aber alle sagen, nee, das kauft keiner, dann wird das durchgesetzt und dann kriegt dieser junge, aufstrebende Süßigkeiten-Designer, kriegt seinen Kopf durch und endlich im Regal und will genau mich targeten damit, mit diesem Produkt und schafft das auch, aber ich kann es gerade leider nicht kaufen. Das finde ich auch spannend, weil wie wird man sowas?
Also das sind so ganz coole Berufe,
auch Burger-Designer bei McDonalds und sowas, sind ja alles
Berufe. Soßen, ey, wir müssen
mal Tarkan, Tarkan, Autor
bei Gute Arbeit, hat einen
Onkel oder Opa oder sowas, der
die Soße des Big Tasty
entwickelt hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir jetzt gerade hier
interner spoilern,
aber das ist ja richtig, weil das ist ja eine Legende, weil ich meine, es gibt ja wie viele McDonald's Soßen gibt es denn, 20 für McDonald's, die weltweit agieren, also das ist ja schon krass.
Du mal erzählt hast, dass du jemanden getroffen hast, dessen Onkel die entschieden hat, dass R2-D2, R2-D2 nicht R2-D2 reist. Genau, der sollte das Skript vom Originalen Englisch übersetzen ins Deutsche mit anderen Leuten zusammen und der hat unter anderem entschieden, dass R2-D2 besser klingen als wie es in der letzten Version noch hieß, R2-D2, hat er entschieden, aber der ist leider tot mittlerweile, den würde ich auch gerne interviewen, vielleicht kommen wir an den Tarkant und an den Socentypen ran. Ja, oder wir machen so eine Seance, wo wir dann dieses Brett haben, so ein Ouija-Brett Stimmt, das können wir auch machen, ja. Und ein Gleiserrücken. Aber das zum Beispiel, der meinte auch, dass zum Beispiel der, der die Burger- die Big Mac-Soße entwickelt hat, sowas wie eine Legende ist. Weil man lebt ja immer in seiner eigenen Welt. Für uns ist zum Beispiel Comedy ist Louis C.K. der King, aber für den normalen Typen auf der Strasse halt völlig egal. Genauso sind andere Welten halt dann der Soßentyp ist halt dann der allerkrasseste, aber wir können das gar nicht so nachvollziehen. Und in der Übersetzerwelt ist der, der R2-D2 durchgesetzt hat, einfach der grösste Mann der Welt. Das ist aber auch eine super Entscheidung gewesen, eine super Entscheidung. Richtig gut. Also macht auch Sinn, weil man würde es ja auch so im Funkspruch durchgeben, weil zwei zu nah an drei ist. Das ist ja, warum man zwei sagt, oder? Ja. Wie Juno, Junai. Ja, stimmt schon. War jetzt Julai das mit dem N. Müssen wir, vielleicht kommen wir tatsächlich an den Soßen-Typen. Takan, du weisst, wir haben noch diesen Podcast, ne? Ja, ja, wir wollten deinen Onkel einlassen mit den Soßen-Typen. Ja, okay, ich frage ihn mal. Naja. Apropos Erzodeto. Diese Woche kommt Rogue One in die Kinos. Ich bin überhaupt nicht gehypt, komischerweise. Ich weiß, ich schon, mega. Aber warum, aber du bist weniger gehypt als The Force Awakens, oder? Ja, ja. Warum, warum ist die Hype? Man ist jetzt schon, man hat sich zurückgelehnt, oder? Nee, aber es ist nicht der Trilogiefilm, es ist nicht der, es ist ein Standalone-Film, so mit anderen Schauspielern, na klar ist man nicht weniger gehypt. Aber ist nicht die neue Trilogie noch spannender, weil jetzt kann man dabei sein, wie ein ganz neues Teil des Franchises beginnt. Ja, eben, das ist doch cooler alles, alles dann ist cooler. Aber eigentlich, ich glaube, alle Star-Wars-Fans sind jetzt so ein bisschen, ich glaube, das ist so eine unbewusste Sache, ich glaube, alle Star-Wars-Fans wollten eigentlich, dass Episode VII scheiße wird, weil man dann in diesen Nerd-Rage und in die Diskussionen kommen kann, warum das scheiße so ist, die uralte Trilogie, die neue Trilogie ja wichtig ist für die Star-Wars-Gesellschaft. Klar. Deswegen glaube ich, sind jetzt alle halt so zurückgelehnt und jetzt, okay, jetzt kommt das Yoda-Spin auf. Und diesen Hate, auf die, wer auch die alte Trilogie niemals wieder so gehalten hat. Ja, absolut, ja, genau. Ist ein riesen, riesen Punkt. Ey, ohne, ohne eins, zwei, drei hätte es sieben nie gegeben. So, jetzt habe ich mal was gesagt, Freunde. Wow, da ist die aber aus dem Fenster gering. Jetzt habe ich mal was gesagt. Aber das Spannende ist, dass ich glaube, ich morgen um 0.15 Uhr im Kino bin. Das heißt Donnerstag, quasi 15 Minuten nachdem der Donnerstag begonnen hat. Jetzt steht aber auf meinen Tickets 0.15 Uhr am Donnerstag, äh Freitag, der 16. So, und das ist seltsam. Sehe ich jetzt den Film zu einer furchtbaren Zeit, weil, okay, 0.15 ist keine gute Filmzeit, aber geil, wenn man da in die Vorpremiere kommt, in so eine Premierevorstellung. Aber an einem Freitag drauf um 0.15, das ist die schlimmste Zeit, die man sich vorstellen kann. Ach so, du bist dir nicht sicher, ob du einen Tag zu spät bist und du 24 Stunden zu spät bist. Entweder bin ich in der besten Vorstellung und in der miserabelsten Vorstellung, noch sehr nah am Eröffnungstag, aber zu einer furchtbaren Zeit. Aber ich glaube, die würden nicht, wenn es nicht die Vorpremiere ist, eine Vorstellung um 0.15 Uhr machen, oder? Ich hätte auch angerufen, da hat sie es auch gesagt, die Frau von dem Kino, hat mir aber auch nicht weiterhelfen können, weil das Datum meiner Online-Tickets ist offensichtlich Freitag, 0.15 Uhr, aber die haben da gar keine Vorstellung. Ich gehe da morgen hin zum Kino und ich war genauso verwirrt wie die. Ich habe da angerufen und dann haben wir auch beide so am Taschenrechner gesessen. Warte mal, Pi halbe hoch? Nee, du musst den Umfang geteilt durch zwei und den Wurzel aus Pi. Aber das, nee, ich habe bis heute nicht genau verstanden, wann ich da im Kino bin. Aber ich glaube morgen Abend und nur 15, also Donnerstag. Morgen ist doch Mittwoch. Ja, Mittwoch auf Donnerstag. Donnerstag fängt der Film ja an, aber Freitag steht auf den Karten drauf. Es macht absolut keinen Sinn. Boah, das wäre echt schade, wenn du da stehst mit deinem Chewbacca-Kostüm mit einem Lichtschwert, irgendwie kanonisch nicht ganz proper und dann nicht reingelassen wirst. Und dann hängst du so mit einem Ohr in der Nachbarstadt von der Stadt, in der ich aufgewachsen bin. Da war die Schule, in der ich gegangen bin, das Gymnasium. Und da gab es ein Kino. Und dann ein Schulkamerad von mir hat genau neben dem Kino gewohnt, genau neben dem Kino. Und es war jetzt halt auch nicht das grösste Kino, das war jetzt kein Cineplex, sondern halt so ein kleines Stadtkino. Wo die Wände sehr dünn waren. Ja, da konnte der halt immer aus seinem Baumhaus raus, ist er über den Zaun geklettert und ist halt dann an der Tür gehört. Und er hat dann irgendwann auch so mit so einem Dosentelefon, hat er dann an die Tür geklebt, während er vor und er sass dann in seinem Baumhaus und hat die Filme gehört und da dachte ich mir, Alter. Aber leider gab es so derzeit halt nur Stummfilme, von daher war das nicht so eine gute Zeit für ihn. Aber das ist so ein richtiger Wes Anderson Move, wo hier so ein kleiner Junge mit grossen Augen in seinem Baumhaus sitzt, mit dem Dosentelefon, weil er es sich nicht leisten kann, und der dann danach irgendwie Tonmann im Film wird. Ja, genau. Beste Story, was ist da geworden? Arbeitlos. Ja. Leider. Diese Scheiß-Realität! Ja, es ist lame. Ich hasse sie. Realität ist lame. Oh Mann, ey. Aber das ist wirklich ärgerlich, wenn ihr das so spät seht. Da stehe er weinend. Was machen die denn mit mir, wenn so ein grosser weinender Junge in so einem Teddybärenkostüm rumsteht und einfach in einem Lobby. Ich glaube, man kommt mit einem tränenverquollenen Och bitte relativ weit im Leben, oder? Ich glaube, man kann, wenn man sagt, man hat irgendwie zwei Euro zu wenig und sagt, Och bitte. Weinen hat die maximale Auswirkung auf Dinge. Als Kind sowieso, du kriegst auf, was du willst, als Erwachsener kriegst du auf das Gegenteil von dem, was du willst, weil Leute dich für verrückt erhalten meistens. Wenn du in der Öffentlichkeit weinst, als Kind normal, als Erwachsener, strange, sehr strange.
Du wirst eher irgendwie, es werden Verwandte von dir angerufen oder so, die dich abholen sollen, die sind so deine Psyche besorgt, wenn du weinst in der Öffentlichkeit, glaube ich, tendenziell eher.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ich versuch mal alles, ganz strange. Ja, aber ich bin schon gehypt. Doch, schon Bock drauf. Schon ein bisschen Bock drauf. Ja, cool. Können wir uns auf eine Spezialfolge Antenne Alda ranfreuen? Ja. Mit Feedback und Kritik. Mit Feedback an den Regisseur. Wir haben halt noch darüber gesprochen, wie wir damals aufgenommen haben Dinge. Jetzt kommt so ein Luke-Mockridge-Part, aber viel Spaß dabei. Aber wo wir VHS-Kassetten aufgenommen haben, wo ich mich gar nicht mehr daran erinnern konnte, weil ich habe immer die Ski-Urlaubs-Videos meiner Eltern überspielt und dann war immer Ski-Ischkel, haben auf den Tischen getanzt, dann harter Cut, Star Wars, dann lange Star Wars, lange Star Wars, man hat schon wieder vergessen, was am Anfang war, dann Abs da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da ist ja eine Kunst für sich gewesen. Und es war ja tatsächlich so, entweder du hast den Film in Abwesenheit aufgenommen oder in Anwesenheit. Und wenn du ihn in Anwesenheit aufnimmst, konntest du die Werbung rausschneiden, indem du im richtigen Zeitpunkt Stopp gedrückt hast und dann die Aufnahme wieder begonnen hast. Und das war richtig tricky, weil du weißt ja nicht, du musst ja kurz bevor die Werbung aufhört drücken. Und es geht ja technisch. Ich dachte irgendwann, ich hab's raus. Diese Werbung kommt immer relativ am Ende des Blogs. Solche Theorien hatte ich auch. Ich habe auch mitgezählt, die Spots, aber es hat auch nicht immer gepasst, weil es ist ja die Länge. Wahrscheinlich hätte man erst die Stockung. Die sind immer dankbar, weil die dann immer das Pro-7-Trailer machen. Für Sendungen. Da kannst du halt da schon aufhören, dann weißt du, es ist ungefähr gleich vorbei. Aber auch da war es teilweise immer so, wenn du dann nochmal neu draufgedrückt hast, dann hat die Kassette so einen Teil des Bandes nicht bespielt, sondern irgendwie da was freigelassen. Das heißt, du hattest dann immer, kurz bis zur Werbung, hast dann nochmal das Originalmaterial gesehen, für einen kurzen Moment, was ursprünglich, also hast nochmal deine Eltern Ich war nochmal kurz in Ischgl. Genau, hast nochmal kurz deine Eltern auf der Piste gesehen und dann ging Star Wars weiter mit dem zweiten Teil nach der Werbung. Also ganz abgefahren, das war schon richtig verrückt. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber ich habe auch oft, der Vater eines Schulkollegen hat mir oft Videos gebrannt, Filme, Kinofilme gebrannt, die noch nicht auf DVD erschienen waren, weil er sie im Kino gefilmt hat. Das war damals der neue heiße Scheiß. Hatte ich auch eine, ja. Und dann sind einfach Leute durchs Bild gegangen. Da hat man oft einfach gesehen, dass zwischendurch, man ist in der krassen Herr-der-Ringe-Szene, oh, schafft es Arwen Aragon zu retten? Und dann sitzt man da, oh nein, nein, nein, und dann kommt so ein schwarzer Schattenstück auf, mit so einem Popcorn auf dem Sehen. Wer ist das Gimli? Der sich umdreht und aufs Klo geht. Man hört zwischendurch auch, wie der Vater den Film kommentiert. So eine Audiospur, die man nicht will. Aber das war echt sehr. Aber so eine VHS hatte ich auch mal. Das war ganz merkwürdig. Das wusste ich auch nicht, was es war. Es gab auch immer so eine VHS, das ist jetzt schon sehr Luke Mockridge-ig, aber wir hören gleich auf, aber eine VHS, die so oft auch überspielt wurde, dass sie komplett kaputt war schon, dass sie so oft auf dem Schulhofhof umhergereicht wurde, also auf Pornos und dann auf andere übergespielt wurden und dadurch wurde die halt so oft das Band hin und her gezogen, dass es halt irgendwann kaputt ging und irgendwann war der Letzte hatte halt wirklich nur noch Rauschen drin einfach, was dann echt nochmal so ein ganz eigener Zauber war. Es gibt noch irgendwo ein Video, das wollte ich mal bei Ups die Pannenschau einreichen von mir, wie ich gefilmt werde, wie ich noch ganz klein war und irgendwas in der Mülltonne suche, irgendwie hochkomme, weil er irgendwie so eine Treppe war, was in der Mülltonne suche, in so einer grossen, grünen und kopfüber reinfalle. Das suche ich nochmal. Da habe ich einfach mal Lust, das rauszusuchen. Das versuche ich nochmal rauszufinden. Und ich habe auch immer Tonspiel, also ich hatte eine eigene Radioshow, die Teenies Geldkrieg und Lachshow. Geldkrieg und Lachshow? Geldkrieg und Lachshow, aber Geldkrieg im Sinne von Geld bekommen. Ach, nicht Geld, Krieg und Lachshow. Nee, nee, nee, Geldkrieg. Das geht um Money, dann die furchtbaren Schrecken der Welt und dann um Lachen. Und da war es auch so, dass ihr dann immer so wie Blocksberg, da musste man diese beiden Löcher überkleben mit Tesafilmen, damit man die überspielen konnte, die gekauften Kassetten, und hab die dann überspielt, aber tatsächlich war das so, dass dann die originale Tonspur noch so leicht im Hintergrund zu hören war, und so manchmal lauter. Ja, das ist die Rache des Kopierschutzes. Ja, aber das war dann so der Geist. Du überspielst mich nicht, Bibi! Ja, aber da saß ich mit meinen Freunden im Hochbett, und dann haben die so getan, als würden die meine Radiosendung anrufen und im Hintergrund hast du noch so leicht, Baby, galopp, galopp, galopp
und so wirklich wie so ein Geist von
Bibi Blocksberg, hast du im Hintergrund
gehört, das war auch ganz gruselig, das war auch
ganz cool. Diese Bibi und Tina
Filme, die es jetzt gibt, sind
unglaublich strange, es sind ja
nur minderjährige Mädchen, und
Olli Schulz, und die
haben alle Reiterhosen an in dem Film
und es gibt kontinuierlich
Booty Shots, Bud Shots.
Von den Mädchen? Mega, und die sind einfach noch
Vielen Dank. Und Olli Schulz. Und Olli Schulz. Und die haben alle Reiterhosen an dem Film. Und es gibt kontinuierlich Booty-Shots, Butt-Shots. Von den Mädchen? Mega! Und die sind einfach noch teilweise so 14, 12, 14 Jahre alt. Und es gibt so offensichtliche Arsch-Shots einfach von denen. Das ist so furchtbar. Und da gibt es ja auch diese Mädchen gegen Jungs, Jungs gegen Mädchen-Filme, wo dann Phil Laude mitmacht und Olli Schulz. Was auch eine merkwürdige. Also da denkt man sich, entweder ist Phil Laude jetzt cool oder Olli Schulz nicht mehr cool. Ja, ganz seltsam, ey. Das sind richtig strange Filme, diese voll verhext Filme. Und dann ziehen plötzlich alle Jungs so ihre Shirts aus und dann alle schwitzen und dann gehen alle in den See. Und das sind so richtig versexte Filme. Aber meinst du, also ich meine, die Medienbranche ist ja ein hartes Business, das wissen wir ja, und dass da wirklich harte Hunde agieren, das wissen wir ja.
Und glaubst du nicht,
dass irgendwo in irgendeiner deutschen Produktionsfirma,
wenn man sagt, man weiß,
ja, wenn wir den Pädofaktor um
ein Prozent hochdrehen, dann
machen wir gleich so und so viel tausend Euro
mehr Umsatz. Und die sich manchmal sagen,
manchmal lohnt es sich den Pädodreher
nochmal leicht anzuhaufen, weil man einfach weiß, dass so funktioniert. Ich habe neulich zum ersten Mal vom Begriff Gaybaiting gehört. Das ist nämlich, um Minderheiten anzusprechen, weil Minderheiten stürzen sich manchmal auf Dinge und dann machen die die Indian Communities, die sind eng vernetzt und machen die deshalb gross Dinge schnell und deswegen gibt es den Begriff Gaybaiting, weil dann wird das halt getriggert. Es gibt keine offensichtlich schwule Beziehung in einem Film oder so, aber so halb, damit man diese Minorität anzieht, dass die einfach sich darauf stützen und es gut finden oder zumindest nach Trailern das Gefühl haben, das ist ein Film für unsere Minderheit und die dann diesen Film gucken und unterstützen wollen, aber dann merken, okay, das nennt man, das ist wie Clickbaiting, nur für Schwule halt. Das ist mega fies und es gibt bestimmt auch Pedobaiting auf irgendeine Art. Ja klar. Das ist echt, das ist gemein, gemein, aber nachvollziehbar. Aber ist es nicht klüger, eine Mehrheit zu triggern als eine Minderheit? Also rein Marketingtechnisch jetzt mal? Ja, aber sind wir nicht alles irgendwie Leute von Minderheiten und sind gut, führ das mal aus. Und sind grosse Minderheiten nicht besser vernetzt untereinander und der noch stärker? Sind Mehrheiten nicht nur einfach große Minderheiten? Ja. Ja, das ist nicht schlecht gesagt. Ja, aber es stimmt schon. Aber zum Beispiel Smithers von den Simpsons ist ja, war ja die erste schwule Cartoonfigur, auch nicht offenschwul, aber wurde tatsächlich deswegen auch gehypt. Vielleicht ist das der große Erfolg von Simpsons. Man muss also beiseite, dass er das gerade, diesen Funfact sagt, mit einem Halstuch, das er heute ironischerweise lustig so mit so einer Schleifchen heute trägt die ganze Zeit. Das ist ganz, ganz falsch. Aber ich finde auch die Geschichte dahinter sehr gut. Meine bezaubernde Kollegin Katjana Gerz gibt so einen Second-Hand-Shop hier auf der Fendler-Strasse. Unsere bezaubernde Kollegin, Katjana Gerz, ja.
Auf der Fenloher-Strasse gibt es hier so, ich erzähle jetzt einfach Anekdoten von Katjana Gerz als meiner eigenen. Ich war auch in so einem Second-Hand-Shop-Laden hier in der Fenloher und da gibt es ganz tolle Kleidungssachen. Sag ich es wie Sie, erzähl es wie Sie. Und da war ich ein paar Mal und da habe ich so ein paar Sachen geguckt und das hat mir alles nicht so ganz gepasst. Und ich habe mir irgendwie geguckt. Hast du ein Kleidchen anprobiert? Jetzt war ich da schon das dritte Mal und habe dann so ein schlechtes Gewissen bekommen, weil ich nie was kaufe dort, weil ich immer nur hinkomme, die Sachen anziehe und dann wieder gehe. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, kaufe ich halt dieses kleine Halshuch hier irgendwie und dann gebe ich das so der Kassier und die meinte so, ja, 15 Euro. Und ich so, okay, fuck, das Kleid hat 10 oder die Hose hat 10 Euro gekostet und das Halshuch kostet 15 Euro, das heißt, und sie findet es halt hässlich und benutzt nicht, deswegen habe ich mir das umgebunden. Das ist eine lustige Geschichte. 15 Euro Halsduch, das wirklich sehr unangenehm aussieht, aber ich finde die Geschichte lustig. Sie muss es nehmen, weil sie dachte, das wäre das günstigste, weil sie nicht immer in diesen Laden gehen kann und nimmt dann das eigentlich teuerste aus Versehen. So verdienen Secondhand Shops wahrscheinlich das meiste Geld, indem man einfach diese Vermissens träumt. Diese Mitleidsgegenstände, ja, ja. Ach Gott, ey. Ich habe mich neulich gefragt, was wäre eigentlich, wenn Menschen andere Anatomie hätten, wie zum Beispiel Pfauen. Pfauen sind merkwürdig, also im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes merkwürdig. Für Pfauen sind wir merkwürdig. Weil guck mal, die haben eine ganz strange Anatomie. Und dass wir diese Anatomie haben, die wir gerade haben, ist ja auch ein bisschen strange, ein bisschen willkürlich, ein bisschen random. Auch wenn die im Zoo manchmal angegangen werden und so, dann rasten die aus und dann machen die diesen Kranz. Diesen Riesenkranz, wo dann sich tausend Augen angucken. Ja. Auf so riesengroßen Fehlern. Das ist unbeschreiblich interessant. Und wenn Menschen so eine Funktion hätten, wie cool wäre das denn eigentlich? Wenn ich dich irgendwie bei der Arbeit plötzlich mal erschrecke oder so und ich stehe hinter dir an der Kaffeemaschine und sage, hey, guten Morgen! Und dann kommt so ein riesen Federkranz plötzlich und du drehst dich so langsam erschrocken um und es guckt mich so tausend Augen an. Das wäre doch mega geil. Und ich glaube, Menschen würden das missbrauchen, so eine Anatomie, um zum Beispiel Werbung zu machen. Das stimmt. Kann man nicht auch faun, auch Werbung drucken eigentlich? Habe ich auch mal überlegt dann. Aber wie wäre es denn, ich glaube, Menschen würden das missbrauchen, wenn die so krasse anatomische Merkmale hätten, würden die das einfach, ich wundere auch, dass Menschen nicht auf das Stirn einfach Werbung haben. Das gibt es auch bestimmt, zum Beispiel bei Turmspringen und so, sind die auch komplett voll tätowiert. Aber das fände ich interessant. Also ein Riesen-Werbeplakat. Auch im Zoo, warum ist das nicht so, wenn man Pfauen angeht? Auch Hunde zum Beispiel. Hunde bekommen im normalen Alltag wesentlich mehr Aufmerksamkeit als Menschen. Wenn du in der U-Bahn bist und es kommen zehn Menschen ran und ein Hund, ich schaue den Hund an. nicht die Menschen. Und warum dann nicht einfach irgendwie dann irgendwie einfach mal Shell drauf rasieren? Irgendwie. Oh, cool Shell. Wie so ein Brandzeichen reinbrennen. Aber du hast heute einen interessanten Artikel gefunden zum Thema Affen, die sprechen können. Wow! Und das müssen wir vielleicht auch nochmal ansprechen, weil Leute, es wird langsam fucking real. Wir müssen ja sowieso noch über die ganzen archäologischen Funde reden, die in den letzten Wochen gefunden wurden. Und was die alles nochmal umschmeißen, es ist eine Menge passiert, richtig viel geht gerade los. Und heute hat Stefan einen Artikel gefunden, in dem es darum geht, dass Affen anscheinend eigentlich sprechen könnten, wenn sie nur andere Kiefer haben oder irgendwie sowas. Genau, Forscher haben die Anatomie von Affen untersucht, haben den Schädel untersucht und haben den Kehlkopf und die Stimmlippen untersucht und haben herausgefunden, Affen könnten theoretisch sprechen.
Und dann haben die das eingegeben, ihre Daten, haben im Computer herausgefunden, haben am Computer rechnen lassen, wie Sätze klingen würden und haben dann den Satz, den süssen Satz, wie ich finde, Will you marry me, halt geguckt, wie das von einem Affen gesprochen klänge und es würde so klingen. Jetzt geht so eine beruhigende Lounge-Musik los, aber die meine ich nicht. Was das für ein lustiger Gag gewesen wäre, Affen klingen so. Wenn Affen will you marry me? Eigentlich ganz ents schon... Aber es lässt dann aufhören. Nein! Nein, nein, das... Hey! Was ist das? Das ist dann auch... Völlig überfordert. Ey! Warum hat das du nicht auf? Hier ist der Kopf runtergefallen,
seine Hose ist plötzlich aufgegangen,
er stolpert auf.
Will you marry me?
Ja, es ist alles aus.
Wir waren kurz in einer Einspielerschleife gefangen,
in einer
gemerrechtlich schwierigen Einspielerschleife.
Also es klingt auf jeden Fall sehr gruselig.
Will you marry me? Will you marry me?
Alter, ist das gruselig.
Vor allem stell dir mal vor, irgend so ein Wissenschaftler dachte, es wäre total romantisch, seiner Frau einen Heiratsabschlag zu machen durch diese Technik und dann irgendwie im Super Bowl irgendwie Werbepause, eine Minute hat er sich gekauft für 10.000 Euro und dann
Will you marry me? Es klingt ein bisschen so, als ob die die Luft nach innen ziehen. Will you marry me? Oh, Alter. Boah, furchtbar. Alter, das ist heftig. Zum Glück kann ich nicht reden. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das Moin Moin mit mir gesehen habt bei Rocket Beans letzten Freitag um 10.30 Uhr bei Rocket Beans TV Slash Videos Und da habe ich auch ein Video mitgebracht, und zwar das erste von einer Artificial Intelligence geschriebene Weihnachtshit. Viele sagen ja, Maschinen können nicht lieben, Maschinen können nicht kreativ sein, aber heute ... Wer das Podcast so verhört, weiss schon seit Jahren, dass wir fürchten, dass Comedy-Autoren die Ersten sein werden, die abgesetzt werden von der Artificial Intelligence. Mega creepy. Und die haben jetzt einen süßen, besinnlichen Weihnachtssong einer Artificial Intelligence schreiben müssen, den ersten tollen Weihnachtssong. Und es ist auch der erste tolle Weihnachtssong geworden. Geil. Für alle die... Hallo. Wir müssen jetzt los? Wir haben jetzt halt... Hier, Tarkan, komm mal her. Hi, das ist Tarkan, unser Kollege. Und Katja ist auch da. Hey, Katja! Komm mal kurz her. Hi. Fahren wir jetzt los. Ihr könnt die Mikrofone, setzt euch. Wir haben HALB! Setzt euch mal, ihr könnt die Mikrofone benutzen. Wie lange wollen wir denn da hin? Setzt euch mal hin. Hallo, da ist Katja, ich hab deine Geschichte zum Halstuch, hab ich erzählt. Und wir haben deine Geschichte auch von deinem Onkel erzählt mit der Big Mac-Sauce. Wir haben einfach alle Geschichten von euch. Uns gehen die Themen aus, Leute. Wir müssen mittlerweile eure Themen.
Sehr schön.
Grüße an den Hörer. Ihr könnt gerade 30.000 Leute erreichen.
Oh, hallo.
Okay, wann müssen wir los?
Also, Sie fahren jetzt alle mit der Bahn los und Sie haben gesagt, Sie müssen jetzt losfahren, weil sonst ist es zu spät.
Kannst du mit deinem Auto fahren, Stefan?
Ich habe kein Auto mit.
Wollen wir alle ein Taxi nehmen? Ja, nehmen wir ein Taxi. Dann sage ich Bescheid. Alles klar, okay, in zehn Minuten oder sowas. Wir können einfach mit der Bahn fahren, der Bahn später fahren. Da kommen wir fünf Minuten später an. Wir haben gemeint, man muss jetzt gehen. Nee, komm, je früher wir kommen, desto früher können wir gehen. Also in zehn Minuten, dann fahren wir mit dem Taxi. Mega gut. Okay, danke. Alles klar. Gut, danke, bis gleich. Okay, alles klar. Du kannst beim Triumphmarsch nicht mit deinem Rucksack an der Tür hängen bleiben. Das ist nicht möglich. Hat sie nicht verstanden. Okay, hau mal den Weihnachtssong auf. Den ersten Weihnachtssong, der von einer künstlichen Intelligenz geschrieben und interpretiert wurde tatsächlich. Oh, du geh doch mal ein bisschen weiter. Schon lange fragen sich die Menschen, wie weit können die, wir haben heute gehört, die Maschinen können schon alles, sie können Supermarktverkäufer ersetzen, sie können vielleicht sogar bald entscheiden, welche Produkte in einem Supermarkt überhaupt gefragt werden von den Leuten. Stefan bekommt seine ganze Kleidung nur noch per Maschinenversand, aus dem Internet gesandt, ich bekomme meine ganze Nahrungsmittel nur noch über wordofsweets.com. Mittlerweile
ist in Maschinen alles möglich, aber können Sie auch
Musik machen? Können Sie auch Musik machen?
Die Antwort ist ja, der erste. Lehnt
euch zurück! Unterm Tummybaum.
Der dritte Advent. Geniesst ihn. Lots to decorate the room.
Christmas tree is filled with flowers.
Flowers.
I swear, it is Christmassy.
I hope that is what you say.
The best Christmas present in the world is a blessing. I've always been there for the rest of our lives. Humanity die. One minute and a half hour of a day. Kein Satz, ist kein Satz. Meteor! I can hear the music coming from the hall.
Jetzt, achtet auf den Akkordwechsel.
Der angebestimmt.
There are lots and lots and lots of flowers.
Das ist ein Ende, Leute. Metallica, Mozart, das ist ein Ende.
There are lots and lots and lots of flowers. I swear it's Christmas. I swear it's Christmas, sweet. Nope, it's Christmas. I swear. I swear. Vor allem so diese, er hält es für nötig, bei dem Weihnachtenssong zu sagen, Leute, ich verspreche euch heute Weihnachten. Das klingt, so als würde er sich entschuldigen, das klingt gerade nicht wie ein Weihnachtssong, aber I swear it's Christmasy! I swear, honestly, I swear, das ist so lustig. Ey, das ist so lustig, auch der Text ist gut und dieses A hundred and a half hour ago. Ja, aber. Punkt. Das ist nicht so, er hat sich nie mal Mühe gegeben so richtig a hundred a half hour ago aber ohne Scheiß oft ist ja Comedy auch echt eine Sache von Feinjustierung aber die lustigste Zahl a hundred and a half da habe ich auch im Moin Moin gesagt Comedy ist ja auch so ein bisschen den meisten Effekt mit einem Minimumanzahl an Wörtern zu erfüllen. Und man will ja immer so ein bisschen die Wörter, die man nicht braucht, will man ja auch ein bisschen loswerden. Deswegen ist Twitter ja auch so geil, weil man sich so Mühe geben muss, dass es kurz ist, und der gibt einen Scheiss. Er sagt sich, wir brauchen keinen Satz, wir brauchen nur einen Gag, wir brauchen nur das einzig Lustige daran und nehmen es rein, und das ist egal. Aber Aber weißt du, es gibt ja oft die Regel, dass Sachen lustig sind, wenn sie spezifisch sind. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du sagst, keine Ahnung, letzte Woche habe ich gesagt, dass mir der Film gut gefallen hat, nicht lustig. Aber wenn du sagst, vor siebenhundertundzwanzig Tagen habe ich gesagt, dass der Film gut ist, wäre lustig, weil es spezifisch ist. Also in der Situation nicht unbedingt, aber sowas in der Richtung. Aber da ist es perfekt, weil du sagst, a hundred ist eine ganz runde Zahl, machst dann aber noch an a half. Aber 137,5 wäre nicht so lustig gewesen, weil 100 ist eine glatte Zahl und dann brichst du es mit a hundred and a half. Das ist perfekt, das ist richtig lustig, der ist lustiger als wir. Aber dann habe ich mir gestern I swear. Lots and lots and lots of flowers. Woher kommt die Idee, das Lots zu wiederholen? Aber es macht doch keinen Sinn. Überhaupt Songs zu schreiben steht im Kontrast dazu, pragmatisch zu sein. Aber lots and lots and lots and lots of flowers. Kein Mensch benutzt zu Weihnachten Blumen auch so ausgiebig, oder? Blumen, Flauen? Und so viele vor allem, es sind eine Menge Blumen. Die Tatsache, in einem Songtext zu sagen I swear, so als würde man mit einer Bessung. I swear, I'm slim shady. I swear on my mother's grave. This is no bullshit. Du hast eine mega Donald Trump-Parodie gerade gemacht. Ich weiß. I swear on my mother's grave. Bleib zu über Jerry Seinfeld. Okay. Aber ich wollte noch ganz kurz sagen. Ähm, ich hatte vorgestern so einen Aha-Moment bei dem Song, weil ich einen Ohrwurm davon hatte. Und dann dachte ich mir, warte mal, in Zeiten von Brahms oder Wagners, da hat man ja auch, wenn man den heutzutage so von uns vorgespielt hätte, hätten die auch gesagt, was, und hätten auch sogar rüber gelacht. Die hätten auch darüber gelacht über unsere Songs. Und Slim Shady. Ja, aber Slim Shady hätten die ja bestimmt auch, wenn es auch lustig gefunden, oder Elektromusik von Felix Yen. Ach so, du meinst, die Artificial Intelligence ist schon weiter. Ist weiter, ich hätte ein Ohrwurm davon und dachte mir vielleicht, Moment, vielleicht ist das die Musik, die wir hören wollen. Wenn ihr diesen Song ein paar Mal hört, habt ihr nachts ein Ohrwurm vom Lots and lots and lots and lots of flowers. Aber ich mag auch diese No-bullshit-Attitude zu Musik so. Wir lassen es nicht ausklingen, einfach aus, vorhin zu, Stühle weggeräumt,
auf den Parkplatz weg.
Es ist pragmatisch, es ist schön pragmatisch.
Und ich finde, dass dieser Pragmatismus ja auch ein bisschen
im Kontrast zur Musik steht, also diese Kunst.
Zeitsparen
ist in der Musik oft nicht nötig.
Aber die Musik fängt an,
wenn der Text anfängt, und diese Musik hört auf,
wenn der Text aufwacht.
Und inzwischen gibt es kein Zwischenspiel, es gibt kein Refrain, wir wiederholen nichts, es ist alles gesagt. I swear it's Christmas, ciao. Es ist alles gesagt. Hi, das ist echt genial. Aber ich überlege mir immer, wäre das auch so lustig, wenn es ein Mensch geschrieben hätte? Wenn jetzt ein Mensch, wenn jetzt irgendein YouTube-Kanal dieses Video hochgeladen hätte. Nein, aber es wäre so lustig, wenn es ein Schimpanse geschrieben hätte. Ja, aber warum ist es nicht lustig, wenn jetzt ein Mensch, wenn jetzt irgendein YouTube-Kanal dieses Video hochgeladen hätte, mit dem es auch... Nein, aber es wäre so lustig, wenn es ein Schimpanse geschrieben hätte, dann wäre es auch so lustig. Ja, aber warum ist es nicht lustig, wenn es ein Mensch geschrieben hätte? Also man kann Comedy nicht für sich selber betrachten, das ist nur lustig, weil man den Autoren kennt. Kontext, ja. Es existiert nichts ohne Kontext. Du kannst... Naja, du kannst ja auch bei Twitter-Gags lachen, wenn du nicht weißt, von wem die sind. Ja, über manche schon, aber da zum Beispiel ist, ob es 0% lustig oder 100% lustig ist,
hängt nur am Absender.
Das ist schon echt abgefahren, obwohl
eigentlich auch Lines lustig sind, aber nur
durch den Absender. Ja, durch Kontext.
Ist spannend. Er kann mir das auch immer ein bisschen Haltung,
nachdem woher es kommt.
Okay, gut, wir müssen los.
Wir wünschen euch noch eine schöne Woche,
viel Spaß in der Vorweihnachtszeit.
Danke, Herr Fantitze.
Ja, und
für den Abend auch mal zu.
Macht's gut.